In 1983 Argentina returned to a
democracy and at 6 years old I first
used a computer. It was love at
first sight. I lived in a small rural
town with ​​2000 people in the interior of
my country and my elementary school had
bought a computer. Just one for
the entire school and the only one in the whole
town.
Every Saturday morning, between the ages of
9 and 14 years old, my parents took me 80
miles so that I could learn
programming. We didn't own a vehicle
and there was no public transportation,
but since my dad is a mechanic, some of
their clients lent us their vehicles
so we could make that trip.
When I was 15, I had to start working
at my first job: teaching
computing. Since that day I have not stopped
teaching and I continue to learn computer science.
What brings me here today to chat with
you is to tell you about two of my
passions: Teaching and programming. I am Yanina
Bellini Saibene, a researcher at the
Argentine National Institute of
Agricultural Technology.
I am an organizer and part of the R-Ladies
Global Team, I am a co-founder of LatinR,
I am part of MiR and co-founder of
MetaDocencia. Today we are going to learn about
the learnr package to make interactive
tutorials and I hope you can
share the same enthusiasm that I
felt on those trips
on Saturday mornings.
The popular wisdom of the Andean
highlands tells us that if I hear something, I
I forget it.
If I see something, I remember. But if I do something,
I learn it. The learnr package makes it easy to
convert an R Markdown document
like this we see on the left, into a
interactive tutorial like we see
on the right. We can generate tutorials,
statistics, data science,
programming or whatever you can
imagine. These types of tutorials have
content along with interactive
components that allow us to verify
and reinforce understanding. As we see in
this example tutorial, the content
can present in the form of text,
images, and diagrams. We can also
add videos, graphics and customize
the style of our tutorial. On the left,
we have a content and progress bar
that allows us to jump
between the different topics and how far
we have gone. Learnr allows us to
learn by doing by transforming
code chunks into interactive
exercises.
For example, this exercise shows
us the code to create a
graph, if we press the
Run Code button the result will be shown
below. If we change something in the
code, for example we swap
the variables of the x and y axes, and we
execute again, that change will be reflected
in the result and if we make a mistake,
for example, we forget
to indicate which variable is the x axis
when we execute it, a message will be shown
indicating that error.
These types of exercises allow
students to test their
knowledge and reflect on what
they learned. We can also generate
multiple-choice questions, indicating
which answer or answers are
correct and selecting a different
message to show our
students according to the selection they
have chosen. Finally, another great
advantage of this type of tutorial,
is that they can be delivered as a
R package and then once installed,
they will appear in the Tutorial tab
within RStudio, or they can be
published as a web page.
It is very easy to share this material
in this way.
The question is now: how do you generate a good
tutorial? I'm going to tell you my own
secret recipe, based on the teachings
in this book. We can think of this
type of educational material as having two
main components: context and
content, and the context will strongly
influence the final content. To
begin to define this context, the
first question I have to answer
is: who am I generating this
tutorial for? Are they newbies? Are they
beginners? What do they need to
know in order to take advantage of what
I want to teach them? Do they have specific
needs such as
accessibility? The first step to
starting the design is knowing my
audience and Persona Types are a very
good tool for this particular
stage.
The second question I have to
answer is: what do I want you to learn from
this tutorial? Here I have to define
what I am going to teach.
I have to write down my learning goals.
At this particular stage
It is very useful for me to generate a
Concept Map with all the concepts that
I want to teach and how they relate
to each other.
My third step is to search and see if
there are lessons on this topic.
Analyzing how other people teach, what
type of tool they used, and the
sequence they present the
content can save a lot of time
and give us very good ideas. A bonus is
if that material is shared
in a way that can be reusable.
Finally and related to this last point,
I have to answer the question
What am I going to let other people do
with this material? So here I have to
select a user license that is
very clear and explicit, so that both my
students and colleagues can know
how to use my material and do it the
right way.
Yes, I know, there is a lot of work to do
before writing a single line of
code. No don't worry, I have a
package that will help you with this
task. From MetaDocencia we have created a
learning package with templates in
Spanish, where we suggest which
sections and parts a tutorial can
have. Let's see how it works.
We need to have the learnr package
installed, which can be found on CRAN,
and the development version of the
learnres package found online, which
contains the templates in Spanish.
Then to generate a new tutorial, I'm going to
select the File -&gt; New File
R Markdown and there I will choose From
Template. From the list of templates that
appear I'm going to choose Interactive Tutorial
sections. This new
document that is created tells us
in the header that it will be a
learnr tutorial and several
options appear with their parameters and what
each of them mean.
We see there is already preloaded content,
with sections and suggestions. We are going to
run this document to see that,
in addition, we have customized how
the fonts, colors, and links
are presented; with the visual identity of
MetaDocencia. You can find out how
to customize this using our
css file that is installed along with the
package.
Now this first structure that
we propose that all your tutorials
have, presents the learning objectives
as the first option; with the idea that
a person who comes across our
tutorial, at first glance,
knows what they are supposed to
learn with it. Also, every time
You see the box with the little apple,
we are presenting an example there and
we also make available links to
places where you can learn more about
this tool or with examples generated by
others.
The second content that we suggest you
present is the Persona Type;
Again, so that whoever is going to do the
tutorial, knows who was thought of when
that content was generated. We're
Putting links to several definitions of
Persona Types made by RStudio and
by MetaDocencia.
Finally, we present the user license
and here we explain the difference
between the licenses that are for the
educational material: the explanation,
slides, videos; and the source code. And
we also present an example.
Finally, as an optional part of
these tools, we present a Concept Map,
with an example and links to
where to go learn more about concept maps
and where you can see and
use several concept maps already
generated related to data science
and the teaching of R.
In case you are going to add this
section, it is recommended to put it after
the learning objectives. Finally,
the other two sections that appear in
this tutorial template present an
example of an exercise with and without code
and a multiple choice question.
Once the context is defined we have to
generate the content of the lesson. There
are many processes to generate lessons
effectively. At least we will have to
answer two questions: what will be the
presentation sequence of that
content? and how are we going to help
our students to check their
understanding of each topic? The
formative assessments presented at
different times throughout the
tutorial are an excellent tool
to achieve this goal of reflecting
on what has been learned, checking the
concepts learned and allowing validation
of the progress that we are
making.
The interactive exercises and
multiple choice questions are both
tools that learnr provides us to
to help us in that task.
A chunk of code becomes a
exercise when I give it a name and
set the exercise parameter to `true`.
From there learnr generates a code box
with Run Code and Start Over
buttons, which can have code or
be empty. If one writes the code
we will have very useful functionalities
such as, for example, suggestions to
complete what we are writing or
it will also mark possible syntax
errors. For these exercises, as
I was saying, I can present them as
blank or can I present them with code and
that code can be complete, it can
be functional code, or it can be
incomplete. Which presents us with
a range of possibilities to perform
exercises.
I can present functional code and
ask students to change it
to do something else. I can present
code that has an error and ask
students to correct it, or I can
submit code that is
missing parts, such as a faded
exercise, which students have
to complete correctly.
These interactive exercises also
have the possibility for one to
add tips or hints, and solutions.
To do that we generate another code chunk,
which will have the same name,
but to which we add a word:
"-hint". If we want more than
one, after the word hint we will
put a "-1", "-2",
and so on according to the number of
hints that we want to give to
students. To add a solution
we write another code chunk, again
with the same name, and in this
case will be "-solution". Everything
we put in there will be presented
with a button called Hints,
in this code box, and which we will
be able to navigate. The last one
presented is the solution. We also have
the option of copying to the
clipboard what it says on each line and
pasting it into your code so you don't have to
type it from scratch.
The other element that we have to be able
to conduct formative assessments are the
multiple choice questions. For this
learnr gives us the quiz question
and answer functions. There we can define
the text of the question, what the
answers are, with the correct parameter
equal to true, we will indicate
which one is correct and in
the message parameter we will be able to
write the text we want to give as
feedback to our students.
We also have the possibility to
indicate if we are going to allow the
student try again, in case they
were wrong, with the parameter
allow retry equal to true; and we have, in
the case of questions, the option
to change the text of the
submit button and try again button,
allowing us to put it in
our language. Hopefully soon
let's have that functionality also in
the code exercises. Multiple choice
answers are a great way to
catch common mistakes
students often make when
they learn a new topic. If we
we design them properly and include this
type of common error in the
wrong answer, we can detect it and the
feedback we give them in the
messages will be much more
meaningful to help them learn
the subject well and continue on their
learning path.
These are just two of the tools and
we have seen them quickly. There are
many other packages, which added to
learnr will allow us to carry out and
extend the type of feedback and
interaction we can have with
our students. Let's mention
some. For example, gradethis, to make
sure that the written code is
correct. We have a glossary, which will
allow us to have definitions of concepts
that will be seen during the lesson.
Parsons, in order to design Parsons problems.
DiagrammeR to be able to make and
present diagrams and mind maps,
among many others.
We have reviewed the learnr package to
generate interactive tutorials and what
elements should not be missing in the design
of a tutorial. If you want to continue
exploring this topic, I leave the link of
the web page of this talk, where there are
courses, blog post, tutorials and packages.
All in Spanish and dedicated to this topic.
The MetaDocencia website, where we teach
how to teach for free and in
Spanish, and the link to the official
package website, which is in English.
Now you have a lot of
tools to generate your own
materials and be able to share them with
the entire R community.
Lastly, I wanted to tell you that learning
is to acquire power and it is a very special
power, because it does not wear out with use
And once acquired, no one can take
it away.
That's why when we teach, when
we share our material, we make it
reusable, we generate it in our language,
we are delivering power.
I invite you to share your
knowledge, to share your power.
Who knows, maybe a girl or a boy, in
a small rural town, with a
computer in their school, finds one
of our tutorials and open the
door to new knowledge. To a
knowledge that changes their life in a
positive way ... and why not ours too.
Thank you very much for listening to me.